[Music]
president na bu was reelected but I want
to show you some of the headlines now
buk who has turned El Salvador which in
essence was a third world country I was
there about a decade ago and it was very
very dangerous and run by gangs and
there were only certain streets you
could walk down and they had barbed wire
all over the place because apparent
barbwire does keep bad people out which
is why they keep it at prisons and
things like that and borders Etc but he
has one he's turning the country around
there's a ton of investment happening in
the country it is way safer right now
there's a lot of good stuff happening in
El Salvador right now I want to show you
a couple headlines on how the mainstream
media is treating this guy headline from
the AP coolest dictator to philosopher
king naib bu's path to re-election in
elabor interesting they called him a
dictator he just wanted a free and fair
election a headline from CNN in El
Salvador self-styled world's coolest
dictator naib buou heads for re-election
amid human rights concerns he did arrest
a lot of gang members and make the
streets safer but again dictator uh
headline from wo the inescapable appeal
of the world's coolest dictator uh so as
you know words mean nothing I will throw
one more in for you headline from time
world's coolest dictator naive bu claims
El Salvador presidential re-election so
what this guy did when he came in the
entire country in essence had been run
by gangs quite literally my
brother-in-law was living there about a
decade ago and we went and he was doing
some volunteer work and we went and we
had to we lived or he lived but we were
there for a couple weeks in a in like
this little little community that was
safe barbed wire armed guards everywhere
and they had gangs just all over the
place you if you walked out there was a
good chance you were going to be killed
certainly mugged or anything else and
that happened all over the country
people people would literally be in
their homes and then the gangs would
just come in kick you out of your home
congratulations the gang own your home
so this guy comes in he he gets the
police and the military to start
actually doing their job they arrest
thousands and thousands of members of
these gangs and now there is Law and
Order and then what happens when you
have Law and Order on the streets and
this is a message in case you're the
mayor of Chicago or of New York City
watching this show when you have Law and
Order on your streets and people feel
safe then people are like you know what
maybe I'll open up a business how about
that maybe I'll go to the theater Maybe
see what else is happening on the street
and get a slice of pizza and then
economic activity starts happening
people start getting happier they're
flourishing good things start happening
so sort of the reverse of what's
happening in our big cities is what's
happening in El Salvador right now uh
anyway here is video of naive buk who is
being called all of the worst things
right uh much like Malay in Argentina
who is fighting the media and bringing
capitalism back to his country and
everything else uh here he is talking
about how the regime media lies about
him
[Music]
p
EX
[Music]
per
all right so for those of you listening
on audio in essence what he's saying
there is that we are going to have a
country where we are going to stand up
for the rights of our citizens of people
who are functioning in our society the
way they are supposed to for El
salvadorians you he said he says
something to the effect of you know
they're criticizing me because of human
rights violations he says human right
violations for who for the for the gang
members so he went in and he cleaned up
his country he claims there I don't know
that it's absolutely true I think it's
at least trending wise true that they
went from the most dangerous country to
the safest country in the Americas I'm
not totally sure that that's absolutely
correct but it certainly is is heading
in that direction you know there's also
something else interesting about it he
has no teleprompter he's 37 years old he
looks like he's going to go bang his
wife after that thing and I actually
think we need some of that energy right
does Joe Biden and Dr Jill Biden please
Trump and like like there're something
about someone that's in the in the
he's 37 right he's 10 years younger than
me he's in the beginning of his life he
is on the way he has he has a vested
interest in turning this thing around
for his children and everything else and
that's the spirit that countries are
going to need to turn all of this
around